los funcionarios ya están levantando las
bayas y la ciudad se prepara ahora sí
para el final del largo encierro esta
medianoche en apenas cinco horas
terminará el más largo confinamiento que
ha sufrido jamás una ciudad china más
incluso que el de jan y que ha dejado
una onerosa factura tanto en lo personal
como en lo económico y ha generado
fuertes críticas en la ciudadanía
especialmente por fallos organizativos
como el insuficiente suministro de
comida el final del encierro llega con
la cifra de contagios diarios en 31
cuando en los tiempos más duros se
llegaron a contar con decenas de miles
de casos se aplicará en las zonas de
bajo riesgo donde viven 22 de los 25
millones de sant genes es quienes podrán
regresar al trabajo y utilizar el
servicio público las autoridades han
previsto precauciones tras la reapertura
como los tres cada 72 horas para poder
entrar en los lugares públicos o la
obligatoriedad de las mascarillas las
tiendas podrán operar al 75% de su
capacidad de los restaurantes sólo
podrán servir comida para llevar y los
gimnasios seguirán cerrados durante un
tiempo desde pekín también llegan buenas
noticias se han detectado y apenas 14
casos y se han levantado en las últimas
horas algunas de las restricciones al
movimiento